well  that's terrifying one moment  marginally better the worse  worse it's much worse  ah there we are welcome pretend i  remembered your name here this is a  pre-recorded message anyway  i would not want to be in the same  building as that thing i tell you me  anyway thank you whoever you are for  agreeing to test out the wharf stash  automated interview automaton  or for short let's start off with some  quick calibration  all you need to do is sit back relax and  listen to some numbers  okay here we go  now what did you hear numbers good  numbers  keep in mind i have no idea what you're  actually going to say due to the fact  that  as i said before this message is  pre-recorded  but if you did hear something now would  be the time to speak up  don't be shy i'm sure nothing bad will  happen  i don't know what you're going to say so  if it does happen it will happen and if  it doesn't happen it won't happen  that's how deterministic reality works